are voting against actual relief for
actual formula for actual babies
and they vote against it of course they
do of course they do because they're pro
starvers they're not pro-lifers
they don't they don't like women they
hate women they hate babies they hate
children especially poor children who
have to have wick who need snap who need
food stamps they [ __ ]
hate america
they [ __ ] hate it
there's a recall on baby formula
there's a recall
there's a factory shut down
the fda is working to get the factory
back open so that the formula is safe
so it's so it's safe
for parents to give to their babies
got it
the trump administration
stopped dairy products from coming from
canada so there's that problem that has
to be solved which they're working on
solving that issue
to bring in baby formula from outside
the country because folks
you can't make something exist which
doesn't exist in the moment it takes
it takes a bit
but while
the gqp ninka poop let's go brandon
nazis
have been blaming joe biden personally
for the shortage of baby formula for
parents and parts of this country
last night
when they had the chance
to make sure
that our government
could do something like they've been
calling for
192 of them that's right 192
not five not three
not a couple
192 voted for your baby
to starve
your child your grandchild
that neighbor down the street
the person who lives in the couple
floors above you voted for their baby to
starve
and i'm sure i'm sure
i'm sure it's because of radical
socialism
radical social i mean we want the
government to make sure we want joe
biden and the government to make sure
that all babies have food in this
country but when it comes time for us to
actually govern and do policy and make
sure that
the administration has the
relief funds to do what they can do to
make sure that all babies
have their formula [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
we don't actually believe in this stuff
that's what the gqp is about they don't
actually believe in the reddit rhetoric
that they spew
and you think you think these trump
pumping idiots who think jfk jr is still
alive
who think he's gonna be the vice
president or is the president or some
[ __ ] you think these people are
gonna believe facts
no [ __ ] no they're not that's what
that's what the republicans are counting
on they're counting on this
they're counting on these [ __ ]
imbeciles
to believe
their untruths their misinformation
their disinformation that is the plan
folks
and the only way to combat it
is to use the ballot
you you pro-democracy voter you
i'm talking to you
your ballot is the weapon we can use to
stop this [ __ ] dumbing down of
america
the simple fact that we have a shortage
of baby formula in this country in this
country
and we we can't even we can't even agree
that babies
shouldn't starve
no matter what their color no matter
where they are no matter if they're
citizens or they're not or they're
migrants we can't even [ __ ] agree
at this point because of the dumbing of
america
that babies
babies who are in our country
should not starve
what do you want from me
the best news is is we have a democratic
house of representatives
we have a senate that is controlled by
the democrats
we have a democratic president do you
think do you think that if the
republicans controlled the house they
would pass any relief for baby for me
[ __ ] no they'd be yelling and screaming
about it on all their trader tv cable
news networks and then not doing a
goddamn thing
because that's what they are they're
[ __ ] do nothings
they're obstructionist they're
insurrectionist they're fascist
let's go brandon nazis
doubt me i always say that doubt me
i told you to doubt me about elon musk i
was right
i told you to doubt me about being pro
starvers
just a few days ago
and here we are talking about 192
republicans voting to starve [ __ ]
infants
oh well it's got this in the bill and we
just can't stomach we just can't stomach
poor children
we just can't stomach poor children
getting nutrition in this country
my god we're gonna force women to have
those babies
but those babies should pull themselves
up by their [ __ ] bootstraps and get
their own goddamn formula
because
joe biden let's go brandon nazis
what do you want from me
i keep telling you i keep telegraphing
this
and here we are
here we are right now
talking about how the party of the of
the gqp
are pro starvation
after days and days and days and days
and days of telling us
telling us how it's the democrats fault
that there's a formula shortage and joe
biden should do something about it right
now
i don't even need to show you the
[ __ ] proof i don't have to go through
the tweets josh holly marsh
marsha blackburn
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
louie gohmert every last one of these
[ __ ] fascists
matt getz all of them
every [ __ ] last one of them had a
tweet or some kind of statement about
how joe biden's
making sure baby formula doesn't get
into infants mouths
and the minute they have the chance to
actually govern to do something
regardless if it would actually [ __ ]
manifest into formula and the family to
families quicker
they vote no [ __ ] you
but they've always voted no
date decoupled food stamps from the
[ __ ] farm bill which is the [ __ ]
point of the goddamn farm bill that's
been the success of the farm bill for
the last century
so if you want to doubt me that they're
pro starvers good luck
good luck
good luck to you
i i
i challenge you to doubt me
to all you people out there
that actually
want infants and babies to receive
formula after these gqp pro starvers
force women
to bring them to term
welcome to the broadcast
[ __ ] super pissed this morning every
morning really in this [ __ ] timeline
that we're in right now how could you
not be pissed
but i'm so happy that you're here
listening to me be pissed this cathartic
release
of democratic anger
pro-democracy tantrum right i don't know
[ __ ] you you make up your mind
welcome to everyone amanda kimberl
kimberly's here christine is here debbie
from salt lake is here andrea is here
we have uh valerie janie lisa danny from
facebook margie from facebook tracy
tammy matt from facebook joe from
facebook minus robin is here christina
is here robbie is here
jay is here oh my gosh
you guys just show up every single
weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central like clockwork
thank you very much to all the listeners
out there and to all the new listeners
out there remember we are on two hours
every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central on youtube twitter and twitch so
don't forget to go subscribe to the
youtube channel so you don't miss an
episode also we simulcast from midas
touch facebook page
so go over on the books of face and give
us a like over there and if you're on
the books of face don't forget to
subscribe to the youtube channel the
link is right up there at the top of the
the post
make sure to follow us on twitter at
tony michael's pod guess what today
we are going to have the bonehead of the
week poll and boy do we have a whole
inventory of [ __ ] boneheads to choose
from we put up here's what happens new
listeners we put up a poll every single
week on thursday usually thursday
evening
where you vote for bonehead of the week
and after you vote and you decide for
bonehead of the week
on friday in the second hour we break
down me and gabe sanchez my co-host and
executive producer break down the
bonehead of the week
your choice your decision
and we break it down and boy are we
gonna have some bone hints this week the
good news is if you miss the show
you can also download on apple spotify
and google
we have a special best of the week
saturday edition every single saturday
that goes on the directories as well as
we clip out bonehead of the week
and post it on sundays for you guys to
listen to
on the directories apple spotify google
why you're there give us a good review
don't hesitate to give us a good review
i i um
i believe we're going to have rachel
bittikoffer on this
today looks like in the second hour is
when rachel's going to be able to join
us
we're probably going to talk about these
pro starvers
and how us pro-democracy people look
they're using rhetoric
to try to win this election oh democrats
bad democrats trying to starve babies
they're baby killers baby butchers and
all the while they're the ones wanting
to starve children
brown children especially
they're like oh brown children at the
border well
they can starve [ __ ] them
that's that's how they feel
and they voted that way it's not just
it's
it's not just what they say folks you
gotta watch what the [ __ ] they're doing
because you goddamn well bet the people
voting for them are not watching what
they're doing
the people voting for marjorie taylor
green you think they're watching what
she's doing
how she's voting
what who she really is you really think
that hell to the no
if they did they'd vote her out just
like madison cawthorne
when they watched his cousin hump an ass
on video they're like oh
well gonna get someone else
word is that lauren bobert might be next
on the cothorn type list
i don't know maybe we'll get some some
inside video of a bowling alley i'm just
saying now who knows
who knows
oh boy i am i'm actually not looking
forward to the uh
i'm not looking forward to the bobo the
clown
um cousin humping video not not not i'm
that's no one i'm
but you know we don't look away so
that's what we might have to do here on
the tony michaels podcast
oh [ __ ]
we got a lot of we got a lot of news to
get to today by the way speaking of news
we've got a lot of it to get to um not
only do we have this
pro starvers 192 republicans voting to
starve your children and your babies but
we also have uh iraq is back in the news
and so is george w bush um he had a
40-inch slip
where he seemed to describe himself
oh well
hell george w bush and the entry of iraq
war boy it seems like just decades ago
that's because it was
god damn we have malcolm x uh it's
trending pete williams is trending uh
mike lindell and elon musk are trending
apparently either mike lindell is
transitioning to be elon musk or elon
musk is transitioning and growing a
mustache
to be a a pillow tycoon i'm not sure
what it is i'm not sure of course lauren
bobert louie gohmert and marjorie taylor
green
are trending because they're pro
starvers and then pierce morgan a paris
appears to be losing his ratings
on his show which is not surprising at
all his fox news style show
in the uk they just don't put up with
that kind of [ __ ] over there apparently
but
pierce morgan pierce morgan is the ted
cruz of pierce morgans he really is
isn't he
he is the ted cruz of pierce morgans
or he might be the pierce morgans of
pierce morgans i don't know i can't tell
anymore [ __ ] that guy
he's almost almost as bad as this muskie
elon musk [ __ ] have you have you been
watching this guy he whines he
[ __ ] elon musk whines more than trump
you know we thought everyone's like oh
my god if he buys twitter which he's not
he will never own twitter he does not
have enough money he's not worth that
kind of money
he's a
little [ __ ] lying [ __ ] just like
trump
but here and he tanks the companies that
he he he if he can't sell the company
he'll take it
that he owns that he's stolen
the intellectual property of
but elon musk
elon musk said oh i'll bring trump back
to twitter i don't think he actually
meant like he would reinstate trump's
account he was he's just like oh you
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna tweet
like trump and just be a whiny little
[ __ ] just whine about my woes and how
the world hates me
the [ __ ] out of here you whiny little
[ __ ]
him mike lindell and trump both all
three [ __ ] them
well you know there's a lot of news so
let's get to the countdown let's not
waste time let's go to the shitless
roundup start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we have reached the point
here of the shitless roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends of the day
now we go through the news
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
talk about some news uh here you go
here's the uh great artwork let's make
this a little bigger here of our
executive producer gabe sanchez gop
stars babies
it
i i don't even have to go through the
[ __ ] tweets we don't even have to you
don't have to go to the tweets where
they were blaming joe biden and calling
for joe biden to use socialism
to fix the the baby forming the shortage
in this country just it is a couple
hours ago
they'll still do it tomorrow they'll be
on fox news tonight blaming joe biden
that he's not using enough socialism to
make sure
that there's baby formula somewhere
in the world somewheres
gabe sanchez is joining us gabe gabe
good morning our you know
hungry morning either way i guess the
good news is is uh our country actually
voted for democrats so um in the house
there was enough votes to uh not starve
children which is a sentence i thought i
would never have to say yeah you
wouldn't hope that you know again the
party that is pro-life or rather i say
then quotes pro-life
uh is one that would not want to
restrict access to baby formula
especially after they've gone for the
best week and a half
complaining
about how joe biden was the cause right
right well they wanted they wanted
socialism they wanted joe biden to use
socialism right to fix the baby formula
like they were calling for their biggest
complaint was we should focus on the
problems at home don't send 40 billion
dollars overseas to ukraine we need to
focus on the families and the parents
who can't afford the baby formula
because there's a crisis joe biden go
fix it and then he's like okay well
democratic party let's fix this and then
they propose
a solution
to the [ __ ] crisis
and then
they go nah
no no we were get we were we it was all
fake that was fake we weren't actually
that was just [ __ ] to put on fox news
don't you guys understand this jake jk
bro jk all right [ __ ]
[ __ ] boxes that's me and this is here's
a couple of [ __ ] tweets from these
two [ __ ]
skanks and they are they're [ __ ]
skanks man i don't even like to use that
word these countries
these two tweets from lauren bobert and
marjorie's other green these are just
one
one tweet
there were i don't know five six maybe
seven that i found i was like nah this
is good enough like i don't feel like i
need to really
uh harp on them because the tweets speak
for themselves in terms of they all got
one projection oh yeah one of them have
one josh holly louie gohmert uh rand
paul they all if you if you if you
know that they're a gqp pro starver out
there they got a tweet there's a [ __ ]
tweet you can find it yeah you know matt
gates even doubling down to be like the
reason i voted no shut up shut up
don't even you're playing the you know
if i could just be the devil's advocate
for one second don't play it don't do it
it's like
just
actually do what you want like what
you're trying to do here you're trying
to help families you're trying to help
people get access to baby formula
because there's a crisis
oh but then you decide no actually i was
just kidding i'm not really gonna do
that and then you try to double down and
defend yourself as to why you voted
against the thing that you were
complaining there was a crisis about
shut the [ __ ] up man
yeah well you know that's that's
that should just be the uh the go-to
sound effect shut the [ __ ] up because we
got lauren you you make a good point in
this tweet you say the republican
party's platform is fake outrage and
anti-life like they're the death cult
and proof is in the pudding here lauren
bobert matt gatz louis gomer paul gozar
thomas massey and marjorie taylor green
voted against yep
allowing low-income parents to use wic
benefits to buy baby formula they did
not want wic which is like the whole
purpose of wic is to feed the mother and
the baby
like
while they're pregnant and after the
baby is born and it's an actual baby the
wick is designed to give nutrition
our country provides nutrition through
wick and they voted against it because
they don't want poor people yeah
which is the funniest part about this
whole thing game is these [ __ ]
right here
that you have listed probably represent
more low income people
then
and i don't have the list or the
statistics but are probably high up on
the list of actual representatives who
represent the lowest income of the
lowest income in this country and they
[ __ ] voted against
their constituents interest to get
nutrition not a [ __ ] not a [ __ ]
house not a [ __ ] cell phone not a
[ __ ] refrigerator like they're always
going on and on and about not not
[ __ ] not the free healthcare or free
college or free this or free that we're
talking about
nutrition
just just to keep a [ __ ] alive
right
nope can't do that [ __ ] you
these are also the same people you know
you lauren beaubert uh thomas massey
like sending out christmas cards with
their children
holding guns right well i mean
well gabe they would vote for every baby
to have an assault rifle right right
if you could come out of the womb guns
are blazing right they would totally
give you the formula you need right
don't get it twisted they definitely
want babies to have free firearms yeah
yeah we should definitely subsidize
babies to have firearms right everybody
got a gun yeah the the republican party
is pro baby uh probe
republican party is bro uh oh my god i
cannot speak the republican party is pro
firearm right anti-formula
absolutely well why wouldn't they be
right i mean if like george carlin the
great george carlin says if you're
pre-born you're fine if you're preschool
you're [ __ ] yeah you're [ __ ] i mean
unless it's on guns and then you know
right right right then you're cool i
mean you're [ __ ] in the school because
people are you know slinging bullets at
you as long as you've got a glock in the
hand you know good baby with the gun you
know what stops a bad baby with a gun a
good baby with a good baby with a gun
not a not a new
baby who has nutrition right no no no
that's not no can't do that can't do
that
this is more of a reason why we have to
pound the message of voting and i found
this video
um um
from a brittle star
here
he's a great comedian he makes great
videos this is like have you seen this
video yet
i don't think i've seen this one okay
this is this is hilarious this is
hilarious keep your mic on so the
audience can hear you laugh because it's
gonna make you laugh
election day is coming up fast
but seriously does your one vote even
matter
why bother voting
well because lots of terrible people
vote that's right think of the worst of
the worst who seem to benefit off the
back of regular people's suffering the
ones who don't care about anyone else
but themselves except maybe their
shareholders they vote but not only them
the person who cut you off in traffic
they vote the person who didn't hold the
door for you they vote the person who
put up a fossa about wearing a mask they
vote the people who start sentences with
i'm not racist but they vote they all
vote all the terrible people vote that's
why you need to vote you're not terrible
probably i don't know for sure you might
be if you are just ignore this video but
if you're not a terrible person your
vote is super important
so vote
[Music]
and if you're if you definitely
want children and babies and infants uh
to have uh you know nutrition in the
form of baby formula you might you you
might want to go vote yeah um and and
the results are clear and if you look at
the results of the vote for
uh what what's the bill number i think
it's hr seven
seven nine zero yeah seven seven nine
zero hr seven seven nine zero is the
actual number of the the bill number if
you look at the results
um
democrats voted for it republicans
voted against it so
what the [ __ ] are you doing why in the
[ __ ]
are you not out there hitting the
streets at this point uh like i said
here in this tweet uh hr 7790 is just
another example of why we have to stay
pissed and go [ __ ] democrats are the
only party willing to deliver for
americans and really deliver anything
for americans at this point i mean
we literally this party the gqp
bitched and bitched and bitched for
government to do something
and the people who bitched about the
government to do something who are in
[ __ ] government
when they had the chance to do something
while in government right did nothing
they voted no not even did nothing they
[ __ ] said no [ __ ] you well i mean
you've also got marjorie taylor green up
there in the debate trying to defend
herself because he was like name me one
thing if you're reelected what you would
actually do and what did she do and
because he was also saying uh don't try
to place blame on you know the woke left
or whatever and immediately she comes in
and says well the actual people who
can't get stuffed it's because we're not
on committees and uh and i wasn't able
to do stuff because of the democratic
party and they're holding our the
republicans from actually doing stuff
it's like okay well right now the
democratic party came forward proposed a
solution to the crisis that was baby
formula you guys had the opportunity to
play ball and participate and be part of
the conversation and say hey look our
party actually helped solve this crisis
or alleviate this problem and what did
you decide to do you said nah
starve the babies
192 republicans want your baby to starve
because here's
here's the simple facts of the matter
is they're literally
voting no hoping
that babies will starve in this country
to own the libs right to own the libs to
make it a political issue
this is the this is the thing
if this really is a political issue
right if this whole baby formula thing
is politics and you know it's got to do
with politics and you got to make it a
political issue
shouldn't everyone be on the side of
babies should just get formula like that
shouldn't that be the political stand
not like well we're going to vote no
that way that way when joe biden starves
babies because he can't get the money or
he can't get the funds which money isn't
really going to fix this anyways right i
mean i mean the biggest thing that's
going to help fix this
is to actually
work with canada to try to get their
dairy products across the border which
was part of the nafta deal that trump
did was to make sure that we weren't
importing
um dairy products from canada because he
was trying to protect dairy farmers here
well guess what guess guess what guess
what baby foreign is made of gabe guess
what it's
guess what it's made of
don't tell me it's it's milk don't know
well you know you might you might be on
to something there and what no you might
not
wait you're telling me that the man who
was such an incredible businessman he
knows he knows the best business people
the best he has the best business acumen
you're saying that the guy who bragged
about himself and just in in an
incredible fashion any time there was a
mic or a camera and then when it
actually came to making business
decisions for the country
he messed up
uh
is that what you're saying you know
you're what you're telling me right now
are you telling me that the guy who ran
the country four years dropped a drop
dropped and
dropped the protection of americans in
terms of what we were doing to fight
covid uh didn't really do anything to
bring back jobs uh was pushing for a
regulation that would actually make it
difficult for baby formula to introduce
into the country you're saying that's
amazing raised prices on people in this
country in the form of tariffs in the
form of tariffs yeah that dude okay got
it and just be clear we're talking about
donald trump okay yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely the cheeto dust mobster the
orange mussolini jesus
manga king
donald trump um here is uh here's a
great video do you know good trouble on
tick tock yeah um so i go over on tick
tock every once why i try not to get in
the tick tock rabbit hole but every once
in a while i come across good troubles
video this this one is great now if
anyone out there who doesn't know tick
tock there's there's what is called a
stitch i believe is what it's called
where you take a video of a video and
you respond to the video well this is a
stitch of a stitch of a stitch if that
makes sense i mean so it's kind of
stitched together here oh is he he's in
this video is he going back like
somebody stitched him and then he's
going back and stitching that person to
respond and so on and so on and so on
right so good trouble made the original
video about how um
he was surprised not to see the
republicans outraged about the baby
forming the shortage and what he was
trying to say in the video the point he
was trying to make is that people were
outraged about biden they weren't
actually outraged yeah it's just like
the gas crisis right it's just like any
sort of crisis that has been introduced
under the administration of biden they
say biden is at fault despite the fact
that there might have been regulation or
decisions made i don't know for the last
guy the mega king right well the other
thing too is they keep bitching about
inflation and i think i'm going to try
to explain this today to our listeners
why why inflation isn't all bad and why
we are headed for a actual intended
recession because the economy is so good
and people are not understanding this
but let's listen to this video here
because good trouble explains
the bonehead that tries to stitch his
video this is
fantastic how many far right-wing
anti-choice idiots have we heard
creating a huge stir about the uh
formula shortage in america right now
now you see this guy in the front here
in the last year no i've encountered him
on tick-tock oh have you okay well this
guy this guy is a elon stand and i can
just tell like i can tell this guy isn't
he loves
he has to love elon musk there's no way
this there's no [ __ ] way this guy has
never
[ __ ] jerked off in his bedroom
there he he has to have oh
now he hates he hates tesla's probably
but he loves elon and he really you you
won't find you won't find a tesla with
the mega sticker on it'll say that much
right he probably he probably
he probably gabe has even even
went as went as far
as as to um make himself some elon porn
i'm sure these people you gotta you
gotta imagine these elon stands are
crazy i mean they're [ __ ] nuts
i've seen them in my comments and they
are nuts nuts i mean
worse than some of the trump humpers
dude i gotta tell you i you know just
from that tweet that you shared earlier
i that i posted on twitter i had people
who were like oh there goes gabe he's
the court jester and i'm like so you
you're just gonna ignore the fact of
this party not caring about providing
baby formula in a solution they just
they just say [ __ ] the kids right
and then you're also i had other people
in the comments who were like oh gabe
can't think for himself i'm like this is
it's not funny i'm not trying to make a
joke here i'm literally just pointing
out the facts this party had a problem
with the baby formula crisis there was a
bill to resolve this this issue they
said no we don't want to vote for that
bill so
i i'm not making anything up it's
literally documented there is video
footage of them voting there is
documentation of the bill being proposed
but in their and their votes being
counted
i'm just reporting the facts but gabe
that would mean they'd actually have to
believe the truth and that's the that's
the best part about elon in this and
this guy here is that you know you know
that this guy believes all the whiny
little [ __ ]
oh my god this whiny little [ __ ]
because this guy's a whiny little [ __ ]
listen to this little whiny little [ __ ]
here
how much of an echo chamber do you live
in my guy conservatives have been coming
out of the woodwork for the last two
days complaining about this baby food
shortage stepping outside of your
liberal echo chamber would have shown
that that was probably not the smartest
video to make conservatives care a great
deal about the baby formula shortage we
all they care a great deal about the
baby they're not going to do anything
about it yeah no no of course
why the [ __ ] would they do you gotta
point and scream and cry about someone
else causing the problem yeah but not
actually provide the solution why i mean
how why would they even require their
politicians to do anything and maybe
good trouble will talk about this but i
want to remind people that the the
tweets that he's showing right now are
talking about how the fda shut down the
plants that were that were uh producing
baby formula but what you need to
remember
is that the baby formula that was
produced from these plants caused
uh
infant death and so as anyone would do
despite the fact that it was delayed in
when the the actual plant was shut down
is you shut it down so that no more
babies
die
and you want to get it right now no no
we got we have to we have to be
pro-death gabe who cares if those babies
die if the parents and the babies can't
figure out which formula to buy on the
shelf which one's safe and which one's
not well they're that's just on them and
they they need to pull them those babies
need to pull themselves up by their
[ __ ] bootstraps and do something
about it let's listen to what good turbo
has to respond here to this this elon
stand he's definitely um let's see we
crystal had a good point here she says
elon elon fans have pro violence yet
wimpy as [ __ ] vibes
oh yeah oh yeah he
elon stands with a guy in the bar you
know the little skinny guy in the bar
who's actually
right
who looked like ben shapiro [ __ ]
wasted off his i mean just just [ __ ]
wasted can't even stand up he's so drunk
talking [ __ ] talking [ __ ] and gets
smacked once you know he gets will smith
once and lays on the floor let's listen
to what good trouble has to say about
this elon stand also do they okay so
you're kind of proving my point here
little guy you posted a lot of
screenshots of republican talking heads
feigning outrage not on behalf of babies
and mothers who are trying to feed them
but uh the outrage at the biden
administration
you don't care about baby and that is
evidence in the fact that 192
republicans just voted against 28
million dollars in spending to help end
this shortage that i remind you is on
the same day those republicans held a
press conference
feigning their outrage at this shortage
and then they turned around and voted
against this [ __ ] bill you're too
busy shouting about our echo chamber in
your echo chamber to realize how [ __ ]
wrong you are you don't give a [ __ ]
about babies if you did you try and feed
them after you force women to birth them
so
go follow good trouble on tic tac
um you can follow him on twitter too um
if you look
he sometimes shows up on twitter he's
not very active right right here's his
twitter handle i got it on the um on the
the twitter i think i think he posts a
lot on instagram too
if you want to follow him on instagram
or tic tac you'll be able to find you'll
be able to find
good trouble he does a lot of videos
like this and he gets a lot of clap back
from from these uh elon stand types
yeah um you know that's that's the
that's the thing that he's got oh my god
oh
so there is there is some uh speaking of
ben shapiro we were just trying to bench
a beer there seems to be an internal war
over this um
uh 2000 mules have you heard um how
dinesh d'souza and ben shapiro really
are at er really having a feud here
about the 2000 mules and what is proof
and
what isn't proof of right remember
yeah he's the one that's coming forward
and saying
this is not proof
ben shapiro is saying yeah ben shapiro
was saying that which is amazing because
again i said i think last week but i was
like if you lose ben shapiro on an
argument such as like voter fraud or
anything that goes to the republican
party like you you know you're on the
wrong right well i mean
ben shapiro's taking a good bet here
watching mike lindell
and all these trader tv cable news
networks being sued to get their pant
suit off
um
because of defamation
based on [ __ ] lies that are being
told in like this 2000 mules
but here's here's
dinesh this is why these whiny little
[ __ ] [ __ ] they are such whiny
little
[ __ ] listen to him whine about how
ben shapiro doesn't believe
the [ __ ] in his
funky ass film
so if a if geo tracking shows a mule
going from one dropbox to another to
another to another let's say between two
and three am in the morning
and it turns out that on the fifth
dropbox there happens to be surveillance
footage and you know that this guy was
there at a specific moment in a day and
time and you look on the video at that
day and that time and there he is
boom you've proven your case you've
established it clearly the geo tracking
supports the video the video confirms
the geo tracking so it seems so it seems
like this guy thinks just because um two
pieces of evidence are true about one
thing that means eight million votes
can be cast aside what the [ __ ] is he
talking about i haven't seen this two
thousand mules i haven't seen this thing
i mean
should we watch it someday should we
stream it well you know walter masterson
talked about streaming and i actually
messaged walter and said hey have you
streamed this thing yet because i would
love to stream it maybe on twitch or
something just scream the [ __ ] thing
and just ray on this stupid piece of
[ __ ] the entire time because i'm sure
it's just laughable like
bench appearance like this is [ __ ]
stupid if ben shapiro has that stance
it's got to be just completely [ __ ]
lampable
like it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
2004 scumps
we got ty
wait so donkeys have gps i'm so confused
yeah it's really weird
here's the thing he's taking you know
his assumption is that okay this person
showed up here and they showed up there
at a dropbox right i just want to remind
people that at least in southern
california the republican party were
putting up fake drop boxes right that
they were that they were collecting
ballots
uh that were not
actually it was not done in a in a uh
official manner they set up their own
temporary drop boxes to collect
you know these these are ballots right
people into putting their ballots in the
box who knows if they were actually uh
recorded or not they were not
commissioned
to actually do these they just kind of
put them there by themselves they got
called out for it so when people like
dinesh shoes say that there's these
people these these mules going around
and they're putting votes in what does
that mean the scale at which you have to
do that to cover eight million
people is insane well not only that
widespread voter fraud doesn't happen
not only that they're trying to they're
trying to pin the sea this is always
their goal is to get one state you know
that was their goal is to get one state
to say it was fraudulent because if they
can just get one state to say it then
they're all fraud i mean just the
democratic side of the ballot the
republican side about not processing you
got to stop you got to stop the count
but also
keep the count going yeah yeah depending
on where trump is winning or exactly
it really is [ __ ] weird let's finish
his little wine fest about ben shapiro
because this is the best part this is
the best part seems to me
what ben shapiro is kind of asking for
is unreasonable it's kind of like saying
you've got a serial killer he went to
five different homes and committed
murder he left his dna by the way at all
of them we have the dna we know he was
there uh and ben's like well wait a
minute i don't see video of him in all
five homes well yeah that's because
there's only one home that had cameras
and he is on the camera at the exact
time that you would expect there he is
uh but because the other homes didn't
have cameras i can't show you him even
though i can prove definitively through
technological evidence that he was in
fact there if you're not following this
because it's a bunch of [ __ ]
how is he okay i just want to know like
how did did he like get the phone
records of this person because i want to
know these are things that do not come
right this is why we need to watch this
film right i know because this is the
thing tracking someone's phone you are
not able to do that unless you're
getting a subpoena to say like hey look
i have evidence of this crime and i am
an organization like the fbi or i'm a
local
um
organization like law enforcement that
wants to investigate someone
i'm trying to understand here how
janessa souza got
gps
uh
location from this dude's phone right
he's like i got him on camera one place
but i can prove though not documented
anywhere else that he showed up at these
four other places that is not that is
not that is not that is not that is not
how that works jim copeland here on
facebook says prove me wrong
like that's literally it's literally
like prove me wrong i mean
i'm going to make this statement based
on no no evidence or fact do you want to
know why no one is buying this [ __ ]
and why even ben shapiro in his dumbest
of days is smart enough not to endorse
and back this whole
dumb ass theory
go ahead
it's because people like oan
newsmax fox news
rudy giuliani mike lindell uh um
uh why am i playing our name uh release
the kraken oh yeah the kraken sydney
powell sydney powell and all those other
addictions
are are literally
being sued they are being sued by
dominion um smartmatic like all these
places that are actually in charge of
the ballots the machines they're getting
sued by these organizations because they
continue to spread falsehoods and lies
about uh donor fraud or a voter fraud
and how there was election fraud and
this and that it was all this coup and
his conspiracy to overthrow the
government in terms of uh trump being
president
they're being sued ben shapiro looks at
that he's a lawyer mind you
well yeah well i mean you know again
again
in the dumbest of days for ben shapiro
ben shapiro is smart right now not to
endorse this 2000 mules documentary and
i say that in quotes documentary because
it's all lies because you look at
newsmax and oan and fox news and they're
all getting sued
billions
billions of dollars both on an
organization level but also individual
people who continue to spread these lies
like mike lindell and sidney powell
ty says here i can definitely prove that
dinesh d'souza is an [ __ ] oh yeah
prove me wrong prove me i'm gonna i'm
gonna say something right now and i
would love dinesh assouza to prove me
wrong yeah i believe dinesh d'souza and
mike lindell commit fraud yeah that is
financially absolutely i believe they
uh
they overvalue and undervalue certain
items in their products which is their
their pillows and their sheets and their
bedding and their pajamas dinesh d'souza
doesn't on his side were the books he's
like i sold this many books and i did
this he even has a deal where if you buy
mike lindell's my pillow products you
get a free book
now i'm going to go out there and say
that both of these men are committing
fraud
i believe they're committing fraud
speaking of michael and i got a great
picture here i don't know if you can
decipher this for me what the hell is
this what the hell is this people are
comparing mike lindell and elon musk
um because elon musk is getting a little
loopy here yeah
i mean but someone must be paul paul
polly texts
i had to retweet this um because it
appears
it appears that this may be elon musk
trans
transforming into mike windell yeah
transitioning as it were
he is he is uh there is a metamorphosis
happening
that elon musk is now
body shifting his way into mike lindell
because
you know some of the [ __ ] that i've seen
elon musk post on twitter i'm like dude
are you having a stroke right now
or are you
[ __ ] losing it
like did you sleep did you sleep on the
on the my pillow mattress and that like
just like just transformed you into mike
lindell gabe gabe here's the thing like
christopher points out here in this
picture
you see all these you see all these
teslas in this in this picture i said
you don't see a tesla with the bumper
sticker for trump on it let's look at it
look at all these teslas
i mean maybe not um christopher says
tesla customers
based uh the tesla's customer base
according to elon musk i i don't i don't
know if he he's like this is like a
grand scheme like he's like you know
what
republicans don't buy tesla's so what
i'll do
is i'll i'll pretend that i'm gonna buy
twitter and go on this tirade right and
continue to go on this tirade maybe
they'll eventually like me and they'll
like tesla's
um i i don't understand it but you know
elon musk tweeted this speaking of tesla
he says exxon is rated top 10 best in
the world for environment social and
governance esg by the s p 500 while
tesla didn't make the list
esg is a scam it has been weaponized by
phony social justice warriors
so here i'm gonna tell him his tweet
sucks because it does it [ __ ] and she
all of them suck i mean we just need to
go down his feed but here's what i said
about it
here's what i said
if i can get it to [ __ ] zoom in you
[ __ ] whine a lot like you you [ __ ]
whine constantly like i have heard
nothing but whining from this oh my god
and you know what he continues to wine
you know fake outrage or whatever and
he's building his following base where
he's like oh i you know i gained
millions of people
after i started all this and we looked
up the other day he's got
15 percent our [ __ ] bots or followers
what was it 13 million or some [ __ ] yeah
it was 13 million that's ridiculous what
did you send me here what link did you
send them here this is another whining
uh this is a mining like
this is him whining and then talking
about democrats gonna pull dirty tricks
okay okay so so this is this is my
response this is the original
in the past i voted this is elon musk
here yeah this is whiny little [ __ ]
elon musk you know i actually surmised
earlier in the show that when he said he
was gonna bring back trump to twitter he
didn't actually mean reinstate trump's
account he meant he was gonna like pair
it
yeah yeah he was going to transfer he's
gonna start writing
trump tweets yeah right um
in the past i voted democrat
oh okay cool because they were mostly
the kindness party so elon musk is for
kindness
oh okay
right
but they have become the party of
division and hate
so the party that
um
is not
with the neo-nazis and the let's go
brandon nazis
what the [ __ ] happened here
oh i think you clicked into it
oh my god
come on man this is your errors
there we go there you go okay i'm trying
i'm trying here um
i know so i can no longer support them
and i will vote
republican
you know the party that actually shows
up at disney world with nazi flags yeah
or storms the capital when they don't
like the outcome of the election or uh
most recently try to start babies
easy easy easy with the dirty tricks
campaign okay he's because elon goes on
to say now watch their dirty tricks
campaign against me unfold like and what
the f what is this what the [ __ ] is this
he he just he made a tweet the other day
that was like you know i hope he's like
so like if i
uh what i'll try to find it but he said
he's about like if he's if he's trying
to go for the whole if he's trying to go
for the whole trump thing he really he's
gotta get all caps in these things he's
really gotta start to get all caps in
him he's gotta include the word sad he
really has to stop doing emojis because
trump really didn't put a lot of emojis
he's got to start making up words
and and just randomly all capsing stuff
like
like really because should be
capitalized here if he's going to write
like trump right because
division should be capitalized but not
hate
like that [ __ ] and he should definitely
have uh um fake news sad at the end of
this [ __ ] tweet right if he's gonna
tweet like trump this is getting
ridiculous if he's
you know trying to be like trump here
you tweeted your response to him your
reply to him was elon musk paid a
convicted felon fifty thousand dollars
to dig up dirt on a british cave rescuer
who helped with the thai soccer team
this was years ago but
we remember there was a thai soccer team
uh trapped in a cave and elon musk was
gonna go over there and save them and
people like ah no you're not that that's
a really shitty idea yeah an actual an
actual cave rescuer went and saved them
um
you went on to say oh and elon musk
called him a pedo guy and a child rapist
you know like dirty tricks types yeah
dirty tricks type stuff but watch for
the dirty tricks against elon laugh out
loud lol
it's [ __ ] gay it's [ __ ] good it is
insane to think that a guy as rich as
him
right
[Music]
who says uh you know what these
companies aren't good enough i'm gonna
buy this free speech platform because
that's what it is right you know you
could say really whatever you want oh
gabe it's not free speech platform until
elon owns it only until elon owns it
will it be which he already does
apparently right yeah apparently but
apparently he already owns it even
though he won't buy it finalized too
many boxes finalized no he doesn't have
the money yet listen listen listen this
is all this is all yeah you know what
you know what they took they did a
handshake and they said this is as good
as money and a signed contract so you're
good you you own it now you you took the
you took you want to take the reins
right now great we're done
um
elon musk man the guy is uh you know the
richest man or what i guess was i don't
man i don't know right
he really really
yeah yeah he changed his title there
right
but you you look at elon musk and you're
like this dude has so much money he
decided to make himself the victim
literally surrounded my money and
protection and
like no
like no actual problems in his life
right he could buy something if he wants
he could fly there if he wants he could
get baby formula
on demand he could probably produce baby
formula if you really wanted to do some
good right he's so smart he's so smart
he's so smart he he could he could [ __ ]
baby for him in the game he's probably
hit it out but if he really wanted you
know to help he could probably do
something but this guy's over here who's
it's literally the meme of the the guy
riding the bike complaining throws the
stick into the spokes and then falls on
the ground he's like ah
they did it to me they did it to me
like that's what elon is he is he is the
how long how long do you think until we
get the news because he's gonna trend
where he's being fired as a ceo of tesla
there's no doubt i don't know i mean
were
what was the stock yesterday it closed
at like 709 seven well six here here's
which i believe is below the price at
which it was uh financially feasible for
the banking institutions and uh vc firms
who were saying yeah we'll we'll
actually secure the funding it's gone
way lower than that
and i'm not also saying here's the other
thing elon musk could be doing this to
one lower the price of twitter to
renegotiate the price but two he sold
but doesn't that
doesn't that break the deal and it's off
i mean it does and then he's going to
try to argue well the company hasn't
valued what i agreed to so i shouldn't
have to pay this price even though elon
musk is the reason that the company is
devaluing the way that it is and on top
of that he sold you know how
whatever was eight eight billion uh for
tesla at whatever the price was at 700
something and then now that stuck he
tanked that stock and now you know
there's you could also argue that he did
that to manipulate the stock in both
scenarios to sell and then repurchase at
a lower price to get more shares and a
greater stake of the company now it
wouldn't be unlike elon because he's
definitely done stuff like that before
and i'm not saying that he is shitty but
he's definitely shady uh and he would be
one to
uh fabricate or manipulate the market to
his benefit you know whether he actually
wants to or not but i wouldn't put it
past him
mj's always get some facts handy here
she says it's 7 1304 right now so she's
looking it up she's on the she's nothing
i here's here's proof to me
i'm going to show you something funny
here but um this is uh apple's um
prototype design it looks like
of a electric car to compete
self-driving like that looks like my
mouse well uh actually corey ryan fergus
forester says [ __ ] that's a wireless
mouse
if anyone can see here's my mouse right
this looks like and here's the thing
they also make a black version of this
mouse so they literally just they are
going to be making it
they took it and they put wheels on it
right they're going to make wheels on it
tonight they're going to make an extra
large one with wheels on it that will
drive you around wherever the hell you
want to go now i don't know what the
i don't know what what you know
what the reality of this is here like
how long or what you know you know that
companies like apple are wanting to get
into this market that tesla's in though
right they're wanting to enter this
market i mean you can have you even have
established brands like ford and chevy
they're already into the market if not
right you know right they are producing
stuff that would actually compete with
tesla right so here's the thing about
here's the problem that tesla has and
we've talked about this before his
dealership problem because he can't he
can't establish dealerships in a lot of
these states for the laws that they have
um so so
you know an apple may have the same
issue but that's where that's where some
of these um issues are going to rise
with these current uh car manufacturers
like you're talking about chevrolet
toyota
honda you know where they actually have
dealership agreements in these states
where they're going to be able to open
up brand new dealerships where tesla and
apple may not right but the point is the
point is is that tesla now being the
king of the castle and electric cars
don't bet on them being the king of the
castle
in the end yeah i mean there's gonna be
a king in the castle the electric car
but it's probably not going to be it
probably is not going to be elon musk
i mean you know i look at it and i'm
like you know you guys wanted capitalism
you know
free free free market competition that's
happening here like don't get mad right
when you make shitty decisions and you
take your stock
if you're uh if you're musk king your
maga musk king mega holy [ __ ] did you
just coin mega musk king that's mega
king
don't be don't be surprised if you know
he you know falls down the ladder a
couple spots once all these other
competitors come into the market and
actually have something that is either
more affordable or it can produce at a
larger scale or like you pointed out can
actually sell on a dealership lot you
know right right well here speaking of
uh tripping over your own feet
um
do you guy you guys remember we had a
president one time
um he he had a lot of a lot of gaffes he
really wasn't that great of an award
only once right
shame on shame on him yeah fool me six
times
shame on the other guy him again right
right right him him again maybe i don't
know um he's the he's the decider the
great decider remember mission
accomplished by the way mission
accomplished mission accomplished that
guy i think his name was george w bush
yeah um that we had for president you
know it is hard to remember how stupid
george w bush was like i mean going
through four years of trump and still
going through this trumpism thing it is
really difficult to remember the
stupidity of george w bush and i will
say this like uh you know for
for a good majority of people i'd
probably say that you know they probably
don't know especially younger i don't
know maybe younger people who really
don't know who george bush is they might
only know him as george bush the once
president now turned painter right
because that's what he gets comfortable
you either see him at two different
events he's either getting interviewed
because he's painting or you see him at
a funeral for some person distinguished
person could be a past president uh it
could be someone else within the um the
political scene that he's attending and
those are really the only times you ever
really see him in public or video of him
and there's always like oh he gave
michelle obama candy or he's painting
some little thing or whatever like you
always see him as like oh he's now
rebranded himself right to be the 75
year old grandpa right right not the guy
who committed war crimes and
gabe gabe gabe gabe even he knows even
he knows about what he did right in iraq
i mean listen
listen to the video here um and if you
can't hear we'll point it out in the end
it's not that long but listen to what he
says about one man starting a war
somewhere
in contrast
elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
listen real close here because he's
going to get to
why that is
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq what what
what did he say one man
is he reading his memoir right now i i
don't know
the best part is that he's he's
obviously reading it right yeah yeah now
i can't tell if he has teleprompter set
up i'm sure he does right right right
but usually when you're trying to you
know speak at a podium with a microphone
in an audience and there's a camera
you're trying to look at the camera
you're trying to look at the audience
you're trying to you know focus on your
speech you're trying to look at the
teleprompters all this stuff is trying
to help you look like
the order that he obviously is not and
that has never been um this is typical
george bush style where he can't figure
out exactly his police on the paper or
in the teleprompter or if he's supposed
to be looking at the camera or the
audience this is typical [ __ ] yeah but
when he when he looks up
when he looks up
and he uh
he's going off the cuff here right he
may have had a freudian slip let's let's
listen one more time
to launch a holy unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq
[Laughter]
so wholly unjustified
of a wreck now listen to his correction
here right after i mean of ukraine
correct anyway sorry yeah yeah did that
that too
yeah yeah so he said ukraine and then
said
iraq two
right i mean he he corrects himself and
then corrects himself again
of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway
and then they all just laugh it off
and then says oh my it's my 75 year old
mind that is doing that is playing
tricks
russian elections are rigged it really
it really is
like the fact that everyone i mean i'm
not surprised that probably the people
who are in attendance of this george w
bush institute are also someone who's
like yeah
man that was a crazy time i was a part
of that yeah yeah you know i i i voted
to let them go in and we started a
20-year war over nothing yeah yeah right
right dude it was various times man it
was hilarious and then and then and then
the american people voted for three
presidents to shut down that war oh and
and and the last one they blamed it on
him when he actually did bring the
troops home and shut down that war they
blame oh what great times
what great times in american history oh
my god
oh my god this is
uh one more thing i want to touch on uh
because we're going to go to a break
here we're going to have dr rachel
biddikoffer is going to join us very
excited to have rachel talk to us about
what is happening in politics the
midterms and also
um probably what she feels about baby
formula but there is one thing i want to
um
to show the audience here before we get
to that um here is
we uh we tweeted this it says anyone
want to go down
bowling alley or bowling excuse me does
anyone want to go bowling down memory
lane and there may be some emojis here
that have some meaning i'm not sure what
happened with this eggplant i don't i'm
not sure how that i don't know i don't
know yeah i don't know
i didn't i didn't tweet that tell us
about this story in business insider now
we know we know from marjory taylor
green the business insider is some kind
of left-wing yeah oh my gosh
but also keep in mind that's where
marjory taylor green gets her daily
trade information to make her trades
with an advantage right
right exactly she relies on leftist
uh
publications for her actual stock tips
not the financial advisor and not the
insider trading that she clearly gets
from ahead a time uh when they're voting
or getting uh insight into other
companies but what this is about
is
uh as we all know madison cawthorne
there is a group that went against him
the american ruck rakers pack right
these i think they were they were almost
formed just to [ __ ] with him right yeah
yeah they were from what we understand
they were formed just to [ __ ] with
madison cawthorne clearly they have
other people on their hit list but they
were the ones who were behind the recent
releases of the video and also the photo
um we're finding that they were the ones
who did a targeted attack against
madison cawthorne which now has cost him
uh his seat because he was just
primaried
other people on the list turns out
number two
yeah is lauren bobert
so they say coming soon
to uh to a computer and phone and yeah
okay okay near you listen i i'm all for
cousin humping videos right but i don't
know that i have the fortitude
to continue to watch um marjorie taylor
greene or lauren berber in any kind of
cousin humping i don't know i don't i
don't
know
i don't know i'm just saying like if it
includes bowling balls count me in baby
there are holes to plug according to
lauren beaumont and her husband it
worked with madison catherine so maybe
to work with lauren bobert and marjorie
taylor green dr rachel bittikoffer here
tweets earlier democracy
is the ultimate bread and butter issue
that's why we have to go vote marjorie
taylor green lauren boberts out because
once you lose control of your own life
it doesn't matter
what a gallon of gas cost think about it
folks democracy is the issue that is the
issue
and here to speak with us about the
issue of democracy is dr rachel
bittikoffer so stick with us
don't go anywhere right after this break
we have dr rachel biddikoffer the
political great my favorite political
strategist right after this stick around
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out of natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages stay
strong wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for tuning in
sticking with us
we have a very very important voice
and political strategy for all you
pro-democracy folks out there you guys
know
our favorite political strategist here
is dr rachel bennecoffer
doctor rachel mitticuffers
from the pickup truck i want to tell you
guys something yeah okay i was a gr i
was the only sister two brothers okay
his only daughter and my father all the
time would say to me you're rachel
you're my very favorite daughter and i
kind of feel like that when you tell me
i'm your thank you
no you are you are you are i would have
other political strategists on here but
why would i you're my favorite yeah my
favorite i wouldn't have any
[ __ ] them [ __ ] yeah i'm like my
father you got options right
so so rachel speaking of options because
there were some options um in the in the
uh primaries that we just seen this week
so tell us tell us your rundown because
i think there were some important races
in there some of them like well this
isn't a surprise really but tell us what
you what you came away thinking after
tuesday yeah tuesday was you know it was
that for me obviously the peaceful
resistance is the call thorn hit job
right and it's just so important for
people to understand like this
you know this hip job was mostly
motivated by the fact that they could
not control call thorn on the company
secrets right i mean this is a guy that
that scared the living [ __ ] out of them
it wasn't because he was an
insurrectionist it wasn't because you
know he's a big lie
purveyor or just a totally horrid human
being it's because at the end of the day
he broke the number one rule fight club
and talked about the coconut orgy
parties family host right
so you know but in any case like the
rest of this tuesday was really i mean
here's the thing like we the media is
talking about oh all these
insurrectionist one or election deniers
one i was like there's not a there's
barely a [ __ ] person running in a
republican primary right now that's a
liz cheney adam kitzinger democrat okay
and so like when you look at trump's
record on tuesday you know oz win cough
or loss whatever
what we're really they'll say oh well
the trump endorsed canned i've heard a
couple analysts a trump endorsed
candidate lost or only 130 percent of
the vote and 40 you know 50 went to
other candidates that is all looney
tunes dude because it went to other
candidates that are also peddling the
big lie either more or less than the
nominee and you know it doesn't fairly
reflect the success of the gop's coup
caucus and it is obviously now the full
controlling establishment of the
republican party it is no longer a
faction it is the main um you know main
part of the show
well i think i think you're right you're
in your evaluation there and that's why
we need to not so focus on who actually
wins the
um the the ku caucus as you call them um
these these uh traders that we might
have inside of our government our goal
should be why are we and how are we
going to make sure we show up in
november and pile mountains of votes
on top of these trump bumpers
and these insurrectionists and these
cute coup enablers and and that's kind
of the fear here right but that's the
thing we need to use
like in political strategy the thing
that will get people to move to the
polls
is
the fear of hey
i might not have bodily autonomy right
well you're starting i mean tony uh you
know just you know you guys know every
day i wake up and i'm like okay how can
i get democrats to run on on this frame
properly so we have a [ __ ] chance to
survive and i put out a column this week
on my stack that you know explains more
explicitly this is the frame we need to
be using we got to make it a referendum
on them blah blah blah blah but if
you'll notice the the the it is starting
to become
the prevailing people are accepting it
up higher in biden's rhetoric is
changing you're starting to hear
conversations about the the party
looking at running against the
republican party rather than trump so
the influence and the effect that we're
having is is profound right and and
things changes are
in the works i will say but we got to
just keep pushing because we need
people to understand like if the
conversations about inflation and gas or
baby formula in november and october of
of the fall
then we will 100 lose
so we want the conversation to be about
change and we want to paint a very scary
picture of what republican change looks
like right now
so what does that look like because it
seems like it's
it really does seem like they they can't
stop tripping over their own feet with
some of this messaging and they're
putting the ball up on the key for us um
we seen the leak of whatever decision
may come out of the supreme court um we
also we also which
appears to be a leak um
so that it's not so they could get a
head start which i believe they awoken
awakened a sleeping giant in this
country and we're getting a head start
and we can get a head start and we can
get out in front of this so what do you
see what do you see as those key issues
that are going to help us win what
messaging if you could have everyone say
this is the message what would that
message be
so you know i i and a lot of the stuff
that i'm working on now that you know
it's not for uh my own super pac any
worse for other groups so you guys
haven't people haven't gotten to see a
lot of this stuff yet it's being made to
win elections not to win twitter so but
in any case in that messaging what i'm
really focused on is exactly what you
highlighted in that tweet today getting
people to see the bread and butter
connection to democracy and how it might
impact their you know
ability to live a safe secure
you know
fun-filled and american you know life
and so i think that's how you do it i
don't think you make it about abstract
concepts i mean democracy collapsing in
the abstract is not going to do it you
got to make it personal to the voters so
not hey we got to do this thing because
other people are going to suffer we got
to do it the message should should
convey we've got to do this thing
because you and everybody else will
suffer
and number two we've got to make people
understand that you know
you don't have economic prosperity in a
one-party state country i mean that's
ultimately we talk about autocracy but
ultimately what the republican party
wants to install in america is similar
to what the chinese government has under
a communist system and what it is is one
party rule right so we really got to
make a very clear picture for how that
would affect average americans in their
economics their kids their personal
relationships their freedom of speech
all kinds of things but a very um you
know we're very lucky that this row leak
happened in time for us to be able to um
sit and think about how that can be um
translated into a broader conversation
because you know i was talking about how
uh the
the polling on abortion when we asked
there was a poll that asked people if it
would make you more or less likely to
vote if roe got overturned and i put out
that data number one 40 percent of
democrats said that it makes them more
likely to vote compared to just 17
percent of republicans that's the first
indicator of an enthusiasm differential
for democrats since biden was sworn in
basically right so that's a huge
opportunity that we want to take part of
but the other piece of that data that's
really important is a majority of
democrats and independents say they
don't think that it will have any effect
right it wouldn't affect their vote and
the reason they think that is right now
are thinking about abortion only in the
terms of a a row only in the terms of
abortion reproductive freedom that's a
conversation that was an effective
messaging technique under the regime but
in a post-row regime what they are
essentially doing is
is making women less than men under the
law men will have control over their
bodies and women will not
and
we really need to translate a
conversation about rights and uh you
know there's no bigger constituency in
the american public than women it's the
largest voting group in one chunk
i i think i think we talk a lot about
the uh generic ballot um on this show
before with you and i believe that the
generic ballot um is probably where some
of these races like in pennsylvania ohio
those senate races because there's there
seems to be a lot of quote unquote
generic ballot in those states and in
the makeup of those voters but i guess i
guess how how do we go from
okay
so abortion roe v wade to
hey they're coming for you next because
they're even writing bills
to ban condoms
i mean it's not hard right i mean
right i mean like so like here's the
thing about advertising and i've got
some of these ad concepts i hope to
bring to fruition but one of them is
going to be in the summer in the fall
with the jan 6 [ __ ] right and then what
it's going to do is it's going to tell
the story so we have to tell the story
people if we talk about it in terms of
access for these people in red states
and it's disproportionately affecting
women those things are all true and
maybe just you know without in lack of a
national abortion ban the most important
issue is going to be
health care equity between red state
women and blue state women right but
that's not the political argument that's
most potent for us to win [ __ ] on okay
the most potent argument is the supreme
court has just made women second-class
citizenship citizens after 50 [ __ ]
years and the next thing they're coming
for are latinos with birthright
citizenship gay rights and porn because
you got to go have something in there
for the for the dudes
well i think you uh there is one thing
that you said on the last time is like
how do you how do you take the abstract
and make it relatable and i can tell you
from like from within design in the tech
world that i work in you know it's
always a difficult thing because you're
working in abstract like what is this
you know concept or what is this product
or what is this you know uh piece of
technology that you may not have seen or
you never have seen in this application
before you know when it really comes
down to like how would you explain it to
your parents right how do you make it
understandable
so that if you tell it to them they
could easily then take that and tell it
to their friend right like how are you
able to
to not play you know to make sure that
it's not a it's not an insane great game
of telephone but it actually is making
sure that the narrative or the message
is consistent there's a through line
with all that whether it's trying to
trying to marry underage kids whether
it's trying to ban math whether it's
trying to ban condoms right
you know i think a lot of what you said
especially around you know in the roe v
wade group is like it's only focused on
it's just abortion guys it's just
abortion don't have to worry about it
it's never going to go further than that
when of course when you push
that line and you say well what if i
just step over right and then you step
over and you're like well now it's uh
it's any contraception it's condoms it's
uh now checking you and doing um
uh checkpoints to make sure that you're
you know positive or negative in terms
of the pregnancy right there's all these
things that it's like people are like
this is so extreme well
when you give them an inch they're going
to take a mile and i think it's super
super important as you said like you
have to make the abstract relatable you
have to make the abstract something
that's like all right great you take
this now this is the application if it
is actually implemented and to its
fullest extent that they want to do and
i think that's the biggest thing and
um
and i've said to tony before which is
like
there was the
the daisy ad right picking daisies then
you see the nuclear explosion obviously
that's an extreme scenario but it does
make parents go oh [ __ ] no i don't want
my kid living in that world we should be
doing the same thing we should you know
kind of not stoking the fear completely
in a very in a very malicious way that
is disingenuous
but it should be true to what the
scenario is right so
i yeah i mean when i reposted up the
daisy ad i posted it with uh you know a
tweet that said democrats used to know
how to play hardball right because the
daisy ad is one of the most famous
political science or political ads ever
i always showed it in my campaign
strategy classes and um you know it's
extremely effective because it was hyper
hyperbolic as [ __ ] right
and so to answer your question gabe
there's a few things going on number one
there you there is some value in what i
call tell the story ads right so like we
do want an ad in the general running
that tells people
like this is how [ __ ] nuts the gop is
in tennessee they're marrying kids in
mississippi they're banning condoms like
there's a value in a 30-second ad to tie
that and define it but at the end of the
day what you were specifically asking
about how do you make something abstract
uh
abstract become concrete in the eyes of
voters um i will tell you the way to do
that is to is to make the hard choice of
siphoning off one thing and then making
a mountain out of a molehill about that
one aspect of the one thing so to me
much more effect i mean the midas touch
ad was so great and i've had that ad in
my head for a long time but i haven't
made it because i know ultimately i
won't be able to get it in enough
eyeballs because it's just a little too
over the top right but at the same time
that's because the concept can be used
and it is is a major feature of the ads
that i have in production where you take
something and um make it make it
concrete by taking one little piece so
here's a woman she had an ecotopic
pregnancy she had to leave texas to save
her own life because by the time we get
to the fall we're going to have people
living like that right and and she's
just sitting there
in it you know having this angsty
personal conversation with the voter
through the ad telling them look this
thing that i thought was just this thing
affected me and here's how right so
that's how i mean we really can't one of
our biggest problems is selectivity so a
lot of the messaging i put out
everything i put out on twitter is
actually training or like public you
know i want people to take it and start
using it but i get a lot of comments and
someone will say why don't you mention
this too and i'm like dude because you
can mention you got to mention one thing
that's really salient and get that in
and pound that one thing over and over
and like yes all of these things are
[ __ ] important but at the end of the
day we want to pick the most emotive the
most scary the most threat latin aspects
of what's happening with the republican
party we want some ads that tell the
story force
people to look because even after these
testimonies many americans will not know
unless we tell them through advertising
that the republican party had a
party-wide multi-state multi-lever coup
conspiracy to end american democracy
right so that storyteller like news
bring them up to speed ads are really
important by the end of the day this
cycle is going to come down to whether i
can make deploy and fund these emotive
personalized ads that make people in the
suburbs think about their own kids
getting shot their own you know wife
being killed by the state so i think
that's really like how you go about
getting things uh out of the abstract
and into um something concrete but it
really does take discipline and it takes
a specific strategy when you're building
your creative
why i believe some of those messages are
true because i think i think the generic
ballot or the this the suburban nights
as they are the one thing the one
message that will ring true to them is
wait wait you're going to take away my
freedom like right when you when you
start talking about those things you
know freedom as abstract as it is isn't
as abstract in this country i mean we
had people yelling and screaming in the
state of new york outside burger kings
because their freedom to buy a whopper
was being impeded i mean literally
people in this country believe that it's
their right and their freedom to go into
the grocery store and to have 50
different kinds of frozen pizza um that
that that is what they view as their
freedom and i think that is where we
need to be like the democratic party the
pro-democracy party in this country
needs to be right there on the message
just what you're saying like we need to
say look it is about freedom they want
to take your freedom all of it your
rights the whole nine yards that's what
they want because if we can make them
understand that if they take this
person's freedom or this group's freedom
today they erode here they erode there
they wrote here what we will have is we
will have trumped-up white dudes going
in gas stations asking the clerk where's
the condoms and the clerk says
haven't you heard haven't you heard we
ban condoms dummy yep
no man that's exactly right i mean so
like here's the thing like what i wanted
to do in virginia was paint the picture
of life under this republican regime so
that people could see it before
right and of course like once they're
living in it guess what they did they
freaked out if we would have re re-held
the election just two weeks after that
first virginia election
then you know that terry mcauliffe would
have won right and so you know i we have
to paint the picture and we have to make
it relatable to each voter not
you know micro targeting to you know
cuban americans in florida i mean just
this idea that we have to get down the
republican party doesn't make any
messages like that they have a latino
messaging and it's it but it's about us
and it's two things right you fund the
police and soon it'll be you're they're
going to turn your boy child into a girl
whatever right but it's it is not like
they don't think oh in order to convince
puerto ricans uh to vote for that val
damiens we'll need this message in order
to you know what i mean it's like no
dude what we need is messages all about
them if we're not if if the message and
the ad that you're making doesn't may
have one villain the republican party
and two isn't all about republicans and
not about us then you're really doing it
wrong
uh rachel i appreciate you coming on the
show and giving us the lowdown of the
the midterm and please
please please uh i know you're really
busy with all your campaigns and and all
your goings on over there but please uh
keep in touch with us on these issues as
we get closer and closer the one thing
i'd like to invite you we are gonna do
uh we're gonna live stream those january
6 uh public hearings so i'd love to have
um the only political strategist on that
i feel has the message at heart for the
democratic party and the american
democracy dr rachel bittikoffer thanks
for joining us today rachel
uh plug plug one more thing before you
go tell us where they can find your
messaging
you know my i put out i mean there's ads
that they can go and google and watch
but my follow my my twitter at rachel
biddehoffer and you can go to my blog um
my sub stack it's called the cycle on
sub stack where you can read the piece
that i wrote about the midterms
thank you very much rachel we will talk
to you soon my friend have a good one
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
dr rachel bittikoffer go follow her at
rachelfinderkoffer on twitter
don't forget to visit the sub stack as
well
keep up with the messaging rachel's
gonna be on top of it
[Music]
trust me that's one thing she does 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year is pro democracy messaging i still
have her her uh thing up there look at
that look at that i'm not racist
yeah what
you
you
wish
i do wish she's cool she's cool you do
wish you were as smart as rachel i mean
she's she's she's super smart and i love
that she does it from her pickup truck
oh yeah
you know the american way baby right
well you know these elon stands be like
oh rach she must be some kinda [ __ ] lib
like she owns a pickup truck dummy and
get out of here pick up truck there was
one time she came on and it looked like
she was in front of a farm somewhere and
all right that's so american right right
well it is it is um
i guess we have some i don't know ivanka
is trending is there ivanka breaking
news or some [ __ ] ivanka started
trending
let's see yeah what what do we got with
ivanka what's what's going on there uh
why we're doing that maybe some other
friends maybe something i don't know i
have no idea i don't know what's what's
going on of course um the amber heard um
johnny depp [ __ ] is still going on
uh malcolm x if he was alive today it'd
be his 97th birthday that's trending as
well of course iraq is trending because
w
had the affordance slip um it looks like
192 republicans is still trending um amy
adams apparently there's a movie uh or
uh maybe a series i think it's a movie
on hulu called night [ __ ] um she's
trending for that i just wanted to say
night [ __ ]
right why right i mean if i've got a
show and i got a microphone and i got a
chance to record myself and they're like
yeah you can say the word night [ __ ]
yeah that's night night [ __ ] night
night night night [ __ ] so it looks like
uh
oh you're you're back to the uh ivanka
what's going on
uh what's going on in here does anyone
know what the uh what the ivanka news is
why she's listening it's tied to jared
so it must be having to do with money
that they made while uh
working under the the trump presidency
probably crimes that were committed more
than likely is the case is that
yeah there's an article let's see when
this is on february 8th uh
trying to see maybe it's just maybe it's
just everyone's [ __ ] on ivanka that
could be oh you know what i think it's
because now it's
they're
let's see what was this article come up
may 19th okay there was an article that
was on um analysis of hunter biden's
hard drive shows he his firm took in
about 11 million from 2013 2018 spent it
fast the hard driving documents from
senate republicans indicate few of
biden's deals uh ever came to
fruition and shed light on how fast he
was spending his money
so
they're saying
according to his documents which i have
not looked over in terms of this article
to say like whether it's actually true
or not
um
but the reason that ivanka is trending
is because
this article came out i'm assuming and
people are like oh well let's also talk
about ivanka and jared and how much
money they made the
several millions of dollars they made
during the trump presidency so if i had
to guess that's why
it's coming in
um
but i don't know the validity i mean
it's a it's a long article so i cannot
read it in time but it is something that
is brought up around his involvement
with china making money and hunter biden
um hunter bites laptop his laptop he's
got he's you know folks breaking news
hunter biden owned a laptop yeah yeah
so i don't know i don't know the
legitimacy of uh this thing but it says
according to an nbc analysis of a copy
of hunter biden's hard drive and icloud
account and documents released by
republicans on two senate committees
this is probably the same thing
that the mac hates was like now i got
the hard drive on the thumb drive
i've got his laptop right here which
again is like why do you have a copy of
his hard drive right on
a thumb drive it's all [ __ ] um mj
sent this to me this is interesting as
hell
it says the house passed a bill
establishing the first federal law
against price gouging by oil and gas
companies
this is this is neat
now look at the vote count here though
because this is this is the most
important part about it
look here um this is from the c-span
screenshot
the yeas democrats 100 excuse me 217
four nays okay now there's also some no
votes over here five republicans are no
votes so they abstained from voting
but look how many republicans voted for
it do you see that number there gabe how
many republicans voted for it yeah it's
uh it's invisible big fat [ __ ] zero
okay so so not only are these
[ __ ] running around yelling and
screaming about [ __ ] gas prices as
the oil corporations are [ __ ] price
gouging the [ __ ] out of american people
but they're and and they're complaining
about a shortage
of [ __ ] baby formula and the two
chances they get
the two chances they [ __ ] get
to vote for policies that would do the
things that they say they want the
[ __ ] administration and the
government to do
they vote no
they vote no against it against gouging
for gas so when you hear a republican
[ __ ]
moan
about gas prices
they aren't really bitching again about
gas prices they want gas high so you'll
blame it on joe biden
that's what they want they don't want
babies to have formula
so you'll blame it on joe biden that's
what they want because they look back to
um how the former guy [ __ ] up kovid
and like oh well that lost an election
so what we have to do is manufacture
crisis
where joe biden [ __ ] him up that way
the country will vote against him well
here's the thing folks joe biden is not
on this ballot
joe biden's name will appear on no
ballot wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait not one
not [ __ ] he's not going to show up on
the ballot no joe biden's name will not
appear on any ballot
this november not one
that way
fine tony run because here's the thing
but is hunter is hunter biden on the
ballot
his laptop maybe
not underbiting himself the laptop
probably is going to run
um
in a state yeah oh also speaking of
hunter biden i i misspoke as i was
reading uh i said millions about jared
and ivanka and what i meant to say was
billions oh so wait wait wait so what
you're saying is hunter biden's millions
yeah his 11 million dollars that he's
been according to this
is
chump change in comparison to the
billions with a b
yeah with the big b big big b big i
can't even spell b like elon musk be
like yeah yeah
i mean like you know jared kushner got
two billion from the uh as an investment
from the the saudi leader and saudi
prince um and people are like oh he's
just a good businessman and it's like
is he or did he use his connections in
relationship while he was uh you know
connected to trump to advance himself
and his own investment firm
maybe you know it's like uh-huh
most likely yes the big b i i see that
the elon big b is the
the whiny little you got billions be for
[ __ ] then you have the privilege to
wine well speaking of another whiny
little [ __ ]
um oh i'm excited who's gonna be have
you seen the news about pierce morgan
okay apparently his uh his show is
tanking or something of course he had a
show every show that he has it tanks and
every show he's on if he has someone
that he works with on the desk they hate
him now here's the thing
here's the thing gabe i'm going to show
you a clip here that you're probably
going to agree with him on
so
um audience out there know that i
i do not censor i mean here's what here
let's just listen to what pierce morgan
says oh god we said it yesterday there's
going to be some terrible takes that we
see on this topic let's see if it's a
terrible take it might be it might be a
good take you never know cross your
fingers gabe
professional footballers are among the
most lavishly paid athletes in the world
now when he says footballers for all you
out there
um he actually in this country and
because this is on a uk network uh he
means soccer so i just want to point
that out players can earn millions every
month we're kicking a ball around which
obviously sounds ridiculous in an
economic crisis but
oh my god yeah okay so you were right
the complete [ __ ] take
he's like oh why in the hell should a
player get the money that is
the billions of dollars that's produced
by these leagues why should the players
who actually kick the ball around who
make the entertainment who make the
content for these leagues to sell why
should they get any of that money why
did i mean i it's yesterday i said the
same thing which was people who could
not even compete to the level of
athleticism and professionalism that
these women have on a soccer field to
run up and down in
in 90 minutes they would not even be
able to do 90 seconds and pierce morgan
is an example of a man who is attempting
to gaslight this advancement in their
pay
to say well they're just kicking a ball
up and down the on the floor you don't
know that you don't know that you
haven't heard his entire tape yeah right
right right but i'm gonna if i was a
betting man tony
you know as tony might say doubt me
doubt me doubt me
i haven't even seen this and i know
where this is going okay
let's listen let's listen their salaries
are driven by market force they get paid
a lot of money because they're the best
of what they do and they make a lot of
money for their teams and the same
simple economic calculation should apply
to men and women that's why i'm in total
agreement today with the groundbreaking
decision by the u.s soccer federation
not with their decision
oh he [ __ ] totally owned you gabe
wait till we [ __ ] hold on hold on
there's a butt coming what does he say
he said but did he say but but did he
say that
i don't know is he gonna show the butt i
don't know hold on hold on let's listen
decision by the us soccer federation
not with their decision to call
themselves soccer federation it's
football but their decision to pay
okay
he totally he totally can't help but
have a bad take like he's not gonna
correct you but if the rest of this clip
is him saying that he's in complete
support wow okay doubt me i i dude
correct i was wrong i was wrong i i
thought he was gonna go one way with
this and he went the other way oh don't
doubt don't doubt that he'll [ __ ] all
over his good take don't doubt that but
let's let's listen
to what and i said earlier i said
earlier pierce morgan is the ted cruz of
pierce morgans but i think he really and
i also said he's the pierce morgans of
morgans of pierce morgans like he is
he's just a [ __ ] idiot
pay its women team the same amount it
pays the men u.s women have fought hard
for equal pay for years and here's their
victorious captain today
i am feeling extreme pride and to be
able to say finally equal pay for equal
work feels very very good
well she should she's earned it they all
have the us women's football team is a
ruthless winning machine skilled strong
resilient champions they've won four
world cups four olympic goals compare
that with the us men's team which has
won absolutely nothing it's about
pretending to watch as a meghan markle
podcast it's not realistic right now for
all female sports teams or individual
sports women to earn the same as male
counterparts it depends on the sport the
level of success their star power and
particularly on revenue streams from
crowds and television but in this case
it's a no-brainer the u.s women's team
may be very smug
and here here it comes did i tell you
he's going to [ __ ] all over well he
already he already he just he just did
[ __ ]
right right he said he goes in this
scenario where they made a lot of money
and they won all these championships in
world cups they deserve it right in
comparison to the men who haven't done
[ __ ]
but but if it was the reverse [ __ ] but
these other sports it depends on these
other factors and variables and they
don't really deserve equal pay
right and they're smug by the way
they're smug they're smug because he
loses to them so that makes them smug
let's let's listen to him dump all over
his he's gonna take a big big huge [ __ ]
right on his take here
annoying
but honestly they've got every right to
be
they're more successful than the u.s
men's team by far they get bigger crowds
just as many sponsors and actually much
bigger stars
if anything they should be paid more
than the men
god damn it you pierce morgan you
[ __ ]
the way that i look at this is like this
he's still okay he took a good position
in relation to this micro example right
but not the macro concept that is equal
pay for when men versus women so
we were right and wrong right this is an
example
but he did it this is this is what this
is what pierce morgan said he said
women or or these women soccer players
should definitely be paid equal if not
more to their male counterpart in soccer
but with that being said
other women
sports players and athletes shouldn't
get paid as much because it depends on
these other things
that's what
right that's when and and minus margie
points out here pierce morgan calling
anyone else smug is [ __ ] rich yeah
that is well i think i'd be really
smug
right like come on pierce you you
[ __ ] uh dark pepsi says pierce
morgan is thirsty as [ __ ] here because i
i believe that's the case here i believe
the case is is that pierce morgan's like
what do i got to lose to have this to
have this tape right to be on the side
because he's right he's right
when he when he lays out the facts that
the american
the us women's soccer team is much more
successful they have a lot bigger fan
base because they are really good they
are really [ __ ] good they win
championships they [ __ ] win so people
like a winning team i mean gabe's still
a cubs fan but you know it happens
sometimes like hey hey
you know you know we said you know year
after year was like what happened the
next year what happened the next year
yeah you know what for how many years
brown doesn't matter how many years
right right but we did end up winning
did we right the point is this the point
i'm trying to make is that
um
in this country football our soccer is
not as marketable as a sport but the
women's u.s soccer team has made it
marketable because they've won
championships and it's not it's not
because they've won championships why
deserve equal pay because if you look at
how much they were being paid they would
be paid [ __ ] nothing yeah because the
the us men's team was getting everything
and this decision changes that and it
doesn't change it because the men are
better the women are better or whatever
because the women are excited about
about pay sharing even though the men
suck so here's the rub is pierce
morgan's like because these vaginas are
good at soccer
we may pay them but the minute
the minute the minute that the men would
be better than the women women he
wouldn't think but the women the women
who are getting equal pay now you don't
see them going well we should be paid
more than the men
we should be paid more than them because
we're better we win more championships
it only gives you it only gives you a
sense
of where we are headed in this world if
we really can get in a situation
where women are equal they have equality
and and we can actually get women in a
position
where they can rule the world and they
can be in control of things like i don't
know policy and government much better
[ __ ] off because we won't have this
[ __ ] dick measuring contest like
pierce morgan wants to have because he
has a good take here it's an easy take
right but again
the take is
right it's a dick measuring contest yeah
it's female u.s soccer players should be
paid just as much as males u.s soccer
players
but with that being said not all women
right should be paid the same as other
right male athletes i mean that's what
it was in tony michael language it would
be the women's u.s soccer team has a
bigger dick than the men's usa right
it's a dick contest to these guys it's
always the other thing
though the other thing that i meant to
mention and tai brings up here is he
couldn't resist taking a dig at meghan
markle though he is absolutely
so he has to go oh yeah meghan markle's
podcast like
unrelated on right related nothing to do
with it nothing at all and he decided
you know what i'm gonna use it as an
opportunity to take a dig at meghan
markle well it's the same elon musk type
[ __ ] where they're like woke woke woke
wokers wokers mother wokers right right
yeah i think it's that same stupid [ __ ]
because everyone everyone you know
totally [ __ ] shits on pierce morgan
because he's a [ __ ] racist and the
proof is how obsessed he is with meghan
markle like the the proofs in the paper
i'll find you i'm pretty sure it's a
clip of meghan markle being discussed on
on stage but he he storms off and that
was right before
um before he left his last
uh his last gig oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
when he when he he he's a whiny little
[ __ ] so he stands up and he's really
annoying and smug in this clip i'm sure
right and he leaves
why you're trying to find that because
the other news the other reason why he's
in the news
is because his [ __ ] ratings have
tanked
this fox new news style take show that
he's doing um
he really in the uk is not playing very
well apparently his his debut was
over half a million but his audience has
dwindled down the 44 000 gabe
i'd hate to tell pierce morgan this but
our little show right here
on on
on a very good day we get we get almost
almost 20 30 000 people watching
it's pretty crazy people want to listen
to it people well and but they don't
want to listen to pierce apparently and
i'm sure you're going to
send me this link and everyone's going
to know why
why they do not want to hear from pierce
morgan but my guess is is it it's kind
of this
this fox news style show that he's doing
it just doesn't sell
the same way that it sells here
um you know what what what's your
thoughts about that do you think fox
news sells around the world or do you
think it's just
uh no
i don't think it sells around the world
i think uh other countries hold new
stations more accountable than the us
does
and i think someone like murdoch is able
to get away with more in terms of
the news i mean you look at all the
[ __ ] that we said it's like these i
mean like yeah i get like off you know
free speech and all that stuff but like
where where does free speech end in like
the uh the benefit of humanity you know
begins right like you look at what
happened during covet you look at what
happened during the election like these
public these news stations and
publications have just been spreading
lies about fraud or covet is right and
it's not just a speech thing they're
actually damaging and sometimes killing
people right exactly and so you're
putting lives at risk so
where does the responsibility
you know end up is it on the viewer or
is it on the people that are actually
pushing this message out there to
millions of viewers
and i would say that the influence
is 100 percent something that someone
has to be accountable for
um and i think fox news i don't know if
i i would have a hard time thinking that
fox news is as uh
influential
or um popular as it is
uh in the us but i don't know i don't
live in europe so even even the style
but here here
pierce morgan was on good morning
britain which is kind of the the
the same as good morning america here
sort of in that same style fashion um
and i know do you know when this clip is
from this is where him and megan markel
were kind of in a back and forth with
the uh the the the crown over there
this is the weather man i believe okay
where harry harry and megan had kind of
accused the the royal family of being
racist
towards her and their baby yeah um and
and here is here's pierce morgan's
reaction to someone challenging him what
has happened with prince harry in this
situation he walked behind his mother's
coffin
at a tender tender age in front of the
globe that is going to shape a young boy
for the rest of his life so i think that
we need to all take a step back
and i understand that you don't like
meghan markle you made it so clear a
number of times on this program a number
of times and i understand that you've
got a person that look watch look at
this
no way and no way is that smug
right like if you're listening on the
podcast directories right now you
definitely need to come over to youtube
and watch this because this look that
that pierce morgan gives him at that
moment like if you looked up smug in the
in the yeah yeah and i understand that
you've got a personal relationship with
mega market or had one and she cut you
off
see then that's all [ __ ] too isn't
it like
like
to hear her tell the story i believe
it's he they've met each other once and
he acts like
yeah
he's some kind of [ __ ] personal
acquaintance of hers well it was also i
think it was uh
oh i don't want to speak before i know
what i'm talking about here because i
was almost positive oh well i do okay
didn't they okay this is my assumption
that i'm trying to remember back when
this happened is right the story was
they met each other when they were both
single right and he hit on her and she
said
no thanks well i mean it is pierce
morgan yeah yeah
come on
i i mean
it is pierce morgan so
uh amanda
oh here we go okay megan uh morgan and
markle started out on good terms i found
each other on twitter in 2015 and often
communicate in virtually but a year
later things went south of the pair when
mark allegedly ghosted morgan after they
went for drinks in london on the same
night that she allegedly met her now
husband prince harry so
he's butt hurt that when they got drinks
he was thinking that this was something
right he he assumed that this was
something and it was going to turn into
something and that same night supposedly
she meets her now husband prince harry
oh i see
so that
it's not just that it's her it's she met
him on that night and it was supposed to
be he was like this is my night this is
my night and i deserve it to be with you
i am greater than any man and right she
needs prince harry and she's like oh
this is actually a really nice guy he's
friends he's he's a [ __ ] kid he's a
[ __ ] prince yeah and he's a prince
he's a [ __ ] prince pierce yeah dumb
[ __ ] let's listen she's entitled
to cut you off if she
absolutely diabolical behavior you see
i'm sorry but pierce spouts off on a
regular basis and we all have to sit
there and listen 6 30 to 7 o'clock
yesterday was incredibly hard to watch
oh my god
oh my god to watch him be such a whiny
little [ __ ] to walk off the set
what a [ __ ] what a god damn [ __ ] can't
even handle a little bit of heat
can't even handle a little bit of heat
you know he was on he was on cnn for a
while fake news he was he was and then
uh that show also tanked and yeah
and he went and then he went over and
you know did this good morning america
and [ __ ] on that one this one [ __ ] this
this new show you know what you know
what it's almost like there's a pattern
right and you know what i'm saying
morgan keeps [ __ ] well his show
keeps [ __ ] we should use the logic
that that pierce morgan uses for the
women's soccer team in that
since he sucks so bad
like he lost at cnn he lied
good morning britain he's losing at his
show now maybe pierce morgan shouldn't
be paid
all that much right maybe he shouldn't
be paid all that much
that's a that's a good point
maybe maybe the female anchors
and correspondents should be paid
more because they're better they're
obviously better ranked they're better
at their jobs 100 better at their jobs
um thank you for joining us today thank
you for sticking with us um for all two
hours every single every single week day
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific thank you uh to dr
rachel bittikoffer
for giving us your insight into the
midterms and not just the midterms but
also the messaging which is the most
important part
i think about the midterms to get that
message out there so we can get in the
streets
the tweets are important but the streets
the feats and the streets i don't know
i'm rhyming today yeah we're still
working on this one but uh you know i'm
a poet and i didn't know it i don't know
wow yeah
you like that close it out close it
duncan i said
he doesn't like the dad jokes folks no
no it's not that i don't like it i feel
like you just gotta end on a high note
you know oh oh you're saying that's a
good joke that's what i was saying it
was pretty good you know whether you
planned it or not it was good horrible
but now the horrible really discussed it
more we've really ruined it right right
now now that we've really beat this now
that's the real that's the real dad joke
is you continue to talk about it how
funny it was
right remember that remember that joke i
told that time at the kitchen table
sunny
10 years ago right for all the dad jokes
go ahead and subscribe to the youtube
channel because you're going to find us
there every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific also go over to facebook
the books of face we are on the midas
touch facebook page we simulcast there
don't forget to follow us on twitter too
tony michaels pod gabe this afternoon
and this evening we have a bone it's
gonna be a tough one it's gonna be tough
to decide who to put on this pole oh
yeah because the audience has to figure
out who is the bonehead of the week but
we have to figure out who is
the three biggest boneheads to be the
contestants for you to vote for and then
and then on top of that we've got to
figure out on our own the people who
didn't make it are there other people
that were reserving right to be like you
definitely get this title that no one
has to vote for you're just a shoe-in
for this right this week it feels like
to me bonehead could be like four hours
we can literally do four hours the last
couple weeks have been uh have been at a
tough call right
last minute decisions or somebody does
something boneheaded like
again we've had stuff that somebody does
something super bone headed on friday
morning and then we're like well
this just pushed this person out of that
slot yep dishonorable mention it is
decided to mention it is and don't
forget because we do bonehead of the
week every single friday in the second
hour of the show but you can download
bonehead of the week now on sundays just
alone on all the directories apple
spotify google so don't forget to
download the podcast there and leave us
a five star review our good review don't
leave don't be leaving bad reviews don't
be doing that
come on like subscribe and
comment whatever the hell you're
supposed to do every single weekday
monday through friday two hours
don't forget we have a special coverage
coming up in june of the january 6
hearings hopefully we'll get some more
information and scheduling on that soon
to pass along to you guys
so stay tuned for that and until
tomorrow
because tomorrow is friday and at noon
eastern we will be right here right back
here right in your ear right in you on
your phone on your device in your
computer
with the pro democracy message until
tomorrow
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking